في مشهد عفوي واتقى مقطع فيديو رده فعل
رجل امن تجاه طفل صغير وجده بمفرده داخل
الحرم المكي اثناء طواف المعتمرين حول
الكعبه
[موسيقى]
للمره الاولى في السعوديه شارك الدوريات
امن بعناصر نسائيه في تنظيم موسم العمره
خلال شهر رمضان وفقا لمقطع فيديو مصور
للامن العام السعودي وفي مقطع الفيديو
ظهرت عناصر الامن النسائي وهنا يستقبلن
المعتمرين
[موسيقى]
اجتاحت هذه الايام ظاهره مرعبه في مناطق
عده في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه رصدتها
مقاطع فيديو تناقلها رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي حيث اظهرت شبابا يتميلون في
الشوارع بمشيه متتاقله غير مدركين لما
حولهم وسالوا اعلام امريكيه افادت ان
الشباب قد تناولوا مخدرا يعرف باسم ترانك
او مخدر الزومبي وهو مزيج من ماده الزمنين
ازلنانين التي تستخدم لتهدئه الحيوانات
الضخمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ببراءه عفويه طفله عراقيه تخطف القلوب
لفته انسانيه وذلك بعدما قامت بمساعده مسن
مشرده على شرب الماء في احد شوارع
سليمانيه شماليه العراق المقطع حصد ملايين
المشاهدات وسط موجه من الاحتفاء بتصرف
الطفله
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء